a new study shows that increasing sleep
could help you lose 26 pounds over three
years the study looked at adults who
were overweight and did not suffer from
insomnia it found that people who
extended their nightly sleep by an
average of over an hour and over an hour
a night ate 270 fewer daily calories on
average sounds simple not for what more
than one third of americans who don't
even get the cdc's minimum recommended
seven hours of sleep a night here to
tell us how to get there is sleep
psychologist shelby harris a clinical
associate professor at the albert
einstein college of medicine good
morning thank you for having me here it
sounds too good to be true 26 pounds
over three years how do we get there
well the study was done in more short
term than that but what they found was
when they took people who slept
chronically six and a half hours or less
a night they actually were consuming
about 270 fewer calories a day so
over a few years if you're continuing to
sleep seven seven and a half hours a
night you're actually ideally going to
lose some weight that's what they're
predicting might happen with these
patients so was this study about me
personally did you guys monitor my sleep
it's one of those things that's
interesting right it's one of those
things where oh wow it makes sense but
most of the studies that we've done have
been on sleep restrictions so when you
take someone who's a good sleeper and
you sleep deprive them we crave higher
fat higher sugar foods and we can't stop
eating as much so this was one of those
studies that looked at the opposite
where you actually try to increase sleep
which is not easy for a lot of people to
do and we found that they eat less i get
less than six hours of sleep and there's
a sleeve of cookies in the cupboard and
i open that thing after 8 p.m at night i
will eat the whole sleeve yeah what we
do is we actually lose the signal that
tells us to stop eating that we're full
and we get more of the hormone signal
that tells us to keep eating so we get
mixed up and then you put the cookies in
the couch and you're going to keep
eating them at night willpower goes out
the window so does this impact other
parts of our our health
well yeah i mean you think about it if
you're going to be losing weight it
probably can help cardiovascular health
also it's going to help the more sleep
that you're getting at night it's going
to help with stress it's going to help
with depression anxiety it can really
impact so many more areas we're just
seeing initially that you'll eat a
little less and think about how much
more that's going to do so a huge number
of americans don't get that minimum
seven hours per night what
recommendations could people put into
place today to just help them get that
seven yeah that's great i mean i think
the basic sleep hygiene stuff that we're
talking about all the time but in this
study there was just one sleep hygiene
session and people really took it to
heart so limiting caffeine within eight
hours of bed or so limiting alcohol
within three hours of bed making sure
that you're consistent with your bed and
wake times and for a lot of people who
don't do that so well there's alarms and
sunrise alarms and sunsets that make the
light go up and down to signal to you
and also making sure you get in bed when
you're actually sleepy that's an
interesting one i think a lot of people
think if you get into bed early you'll
you'll calm down and get tired go to bed
but you're saying you won't fall asleep
necessarily yeah you want to really time
be consistent so your body knows bed is
now a time for sleep and i think the
other thing that's important is that
these things are great if you don't have
insomnia so you don't make sleep a
priority but if you try and do sleep
hygiene and it's not enough there are
really good treatments for insomnia that
go beyond that that you should look into
and speaking of insomnia we notice the
pandemic really had an impact on it yeah
we saw that google searches went up by
about 50 for insomnia in the first few
months and a lot of people across the
world are suffering more and more from
insomnia for many reasons i mean we're
initially there's stress financial
stress homeschooling for a lot of people
not light exposure because you're home
you're sitting so much more so many more
things really and we shifted our sleep
schedule so much more that insomnia has
skyrocketed more sleep you lose weight
you feel better yeah you can wake up
earlier and watch cbs mornings i think
it's a win-win-win there you go i agree
shelby harris thank you very much we
appreciate it thanks for having me